we're coming off the heels of wanda
vision which was so excellent and such
an excellent exploration
of grief what would you say that the
falcon and the winter soldier
is an exploration of identity um and
it really unifies because we have so
many characters in this one
it really unifies everything in their
interaction in that we have sharon
carter
we have baron zemo we have bucky barnes
we have
a us agent we have uh john walker when
we have
sam wilson and each one of them how they
perceive themselves
and how the world perceives them in the
beginning of the series
will be completely different by the end
it feels like it belongs to someone else
it's the exploration of a combination of
identity uh
and relevance um you know
racial tolerance nationalism
what is a hero it asks what is a hero uh
today as compared to what was a hero
so i i would say it embraces some uh you
know not just similar themes but
um we are able with through our
characters you know who are doing
um anthony is uh exploring what it
is to pick up the shield and does he
want what that
is does he want to be captain america
you know he says
at the end of end game it doesn't feel
like mine and
um you know that is an exploration
of why that is and so we really take on
uh and right now more relevant than ever
that this conversation is
being had we also look at what is the
hero um
you know that was one of the the things
that really most interested me about
um this particular story when i first
got involved
which is um you know originally when
this was uh
thought up by stan lee so many years ago
it was coming out of the war it was
coming out of a particular kind of hero
which
you know took on the the soldier warrior
type of paradigm
and now i would venture to say that
included in that paradigm is uh first
responder
so after you know after 9 11 and
certainly through the pandemic and such
i think we would include heroes
uh in a category of first responders so
going forward if if that is part of the
definition what does that mean for
uh a captain america and is is that
captain america relevant
in the same way so that you know was
really
where we went with it nationalism of
course because of a post blip
so um there's lots to explore uh with
with how that world is reflected not too
dissimilarly
you know with what's going on right now
as a result of pandemics and all the
political shifts that have been
happening you know in the last several
years
um so uh and then out with through bucky
he has to
explore his own relevance um through
mental
you know mental health and and uh by the
way the victims of violence which he
he has to embrace his own responsibility
to his past and what he did um
even even though he it was not of his
mind
he was not of his own mind he uh he
still has to
uh figure out how to take responsibility
one way
we need someone to inspire us again
when you signed on for the show what
would you say that your biggest goal was
number one was to create something that
felt
really modern and really relevant um i'm
a pop culture
guy i work in other arenas like music or
whatever and i
and i wanted i wanted these characters
to be rooted
in their personal lives in a way that
audience would be able to say oh man
they
understand me you know what i'm saying
because i understand what they're
dealing with right there so
relevance like really future forward
characters that feel like oh these are
the heroes of tomorrow
is there an ideal comic storyline
pairing like a wine and cheese pairing
to go with the show people wanted to
like kind of get the backstory or is
there anything that you would recommend
i i can't because we pull from so much
that'll never work um but i would say
for movies that have nothing to do with
marvel uh
48 hours let the weapon the first bad
boys
that if they want to know what to expect
look there but as far as pulling from
the mcu and then pulling from the uh
the comic book universe you spend so
many months and months and months
digging there's no way to pick just one
what does it mean to you to explore this
character i know that sam wilson
specifically was someone for a really
long time where people were like why
doesn't he have his own movie when is
that going to happen
but now we get this kind of fleshed out
series what does that mean to you
i mean it was i fought hard to get this
um it just seemed
so relevant again the uh going back i
think i said it's gonna be
i can't remember which interview i said
it's in but the uh
the baggage that bucky and regret that
bucky's dealing with
and even more personal for me the idea
of a african-american decidedly black
american
superhero being presented to the world
at the
on the biggest platform in the world is
a once-in-a-lifetime thing
typically uh when you have two hours and
particularly in the
sort of the mcu story lines of it you
you're in a
a big high-octane race uh to the finish
line because
you know there's some kind of world uh
issue you know some kind of world threat
that has to be solved so it's very hard
if you're if you're
you've got that those kinds of states
for you to then go off you know for a
little while with a character and
meander back and so on because you know
you're you've got to be
focused on on whatever the issue at hand
is
or the idiocy of that issue so in six
hours though
not only are you allowed to uh you know
it's more horizontal
storytelling um and so you you can
weave through that uh not only your your
big a storyline which is going to be you
know
some of the threat but how it affects
the characters what
who those characters are where they go
you simply have more real estate
and more time to be with them so um i
think it was
uh a bit a bit surprising to everybody
involved just
how how much we enjoyed that process so
i look at
uh feature films as being a snack and um
and uh series as being you know the meal
so we're partners
co-workers not necessarily a team no
we look damn good though
you